Hello, everybody. Welcome to another episode of the holistic health hour. I'm Dr. Kevin Connors where we try to our best to answer questions that you might have. So if you have questions, you could use the chat.
You can chat in your questions right now, but if you want to have a better chance that your questions will be answered.
Send them in Holistic Health Hour.com Holistic Health Hour.com where you'll see all our past holistic health hours and very nicely tabbed for easy reference on different subject matters that you might be interested in.
So without further ado, let's jump right into some of the questions that are consummated.
Dear Dr. Connors, I have a friend who's taking diet spacious earth daily on a permanent basis against parasites and toxins and is recommending us to do the same.
Would this be something you would recommend to be good and safe or is there any drawbacks to take you this permanently?
What I understand, diametaceous, diametaceous earth is a binder and I am wondering if you always want to take it without a break or would it be better to switch different kinds of binders and also allow some time in between each round?
If you buy food-grade diametaceous earth, I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it.
To take anything on a constant regular basis like that, diatomaceous earths can be irritating to the gut.
It's always recommended that you start at a very small amount, like a half teaspoon and you work your way up to two teaspoons. Some people are taking table spoons of it.
It can be irritating to the gut. I mean, what diatomaceous earth does to your vegetable garden is that slugs that are crawled across it, diatomaceous earth is little pieces of silicon that can damage the cell walls, the outer lighting walls, little worms and things like that and it slices them open and kills them.
Well, it seems to me that it could have equal damaging effects on the little TD cells of your cell of your apathelial cells of your gut lighting.
Now, typically it's considered food-grade is considered safe to use for humans. It can be good for parasites, it can be good for a cleanse, but to use it on a daily basis forever.
I don't know, I think I would switch off. I don't know that it really acts as a binder. There's other binders that are better out there. I like binders that have a combination of different things in it.
So I know people are drawn to using something like diatomaceous earth because it's so inexpensive, but maybe they're fine. I'm not saying that they shouldn't do it, but maybe think of making sure you're not hurting your gut at the same time.
So I don't see a problem necessarily. I don't personally know of any patient that's ever told me that they've been taking diatomaceous earth for
X amount of years or something like that. Typically it's taken for a short period of time. So I am not seeing any studies of long-term studies of use. I'm sure there isn't any. So I don't really have a real good answer for you there. I apologize.
Next question. If I already know that I what food allergies I have and I am mostly gluten, dairy, and sugar-free already, what type of diet do you recommend that a phase two or phase three lime person follow?
So phase two lime is what I have termed people that have chronic lime where the bacteria has not gone. The bacteria has gone intracellular, but you haven't formed any self antibody. So you're not in an autoimmune phase.
So phase three lime is my term for someone who is now formed self antibodies because of their live infection. There's other reasons why you can develop an autoimmune disease not just because I'm a bacterial infection, a birelia or something.
There's lots of different things that can trigger autoimmune disease. That means you have that your system created self antibodies.
You have to look for with lime disease or if you do have self antibodies, you have to look for what are my triggers. So triggers can change over time.
So let's say I'm dietary triggers are one thing and they're a very common thing. Maybe maybe the most common thing. But if I'm already dairy-free, I'm already gluten-free and I'm already sugar-free, what else do I need to look for?
But still can be valuable to run a CyRx10 profile because you may have developed antibodies to things that are in gluten-free foods and you don't know it.
You might not be noticing any inflammation in the gut, therefore you don't think that food is causing any issues, but it can be still causing inflammation in the gut, not causing symptoms there, but causing symptoms in the brain.
So if you think you're in phase two or phase three live and you're not having any problems, your life is going well and you're not experiencing a great deal of symptoms or anything, maybe there isn't anything you need to do.
But if you are noticing flares, you're noticing symptoms, you need to dig a little bit deeper and see if food is, you've got to look for what are called triggers.
So anything can be a trigger that is setting off an immune response that's setting off a flare. So that can be a food that isn't necessarily causing you any tummy issues.
So I don't have any issues when I eat corn, so I know it's not it. Well, that's not necessarily true. You might not have any stomach issues when you eat corn, but it's causing inflammation in your brain and that's causing your live flare.
So it's still valuable if you're having these flares, if you're having symptom patterns to do a food sensitivity panel.
There's other things that cause flares too. So if you're on the autoimmune course, you'll see that tons of different things can cause flares, not just dietary things.
So looking for things that are what are termed triggers that can be triggering an immune response and triggering a worsening of your condition is what you really want to dig into and look for.
Question from the chat, are hysterectomies a yes or no God put those parts in seems dangerous to remove them if nothing is cancerous there, right?
Well, there's other reasons why a person would have their uterus removed into or they're overraced removed and it's not just because of cancer.
So if a person has a fibroid tumor, for instance, very common non-cancerous condition, but fibroid tumors can lead to morbidities that are very uncomfortable typically lead to anemia is that are uncorrectable.
And you have to have that fibroid removed and at certain point getting the uterus removed may be a better choice.
So there's other reason. So just to do a hysterectomy, just because you're a beyond child buried age and I just want to get my parts removed seems yes, I would agree seems odd seems like, you know, why would you go through a surgery that you don't need to go through, but if you're having issues, then that's another problem.
Of course, you know, it itself across problems, so I know beyond child buried age and I want to lead my ovaries, I just want to get my uterus removed, my doctor's trying to push me to do that.
Okay, uterus takes up space in the lower pelvic area, people that get the uterus moves tend to have end up with ticked bladders ended up with recurrent bladder infections, that's just a possible complication to that.
So there's there's reasons why not to do it second comment come in pelvic organ prolapse to make room.
So if you're having prolapse issues and the doctor is thinking that the uterus is contributed to that, you got to weigh all those things out.
So hard question to answer without knowing the details of the overall condition, but in general, yeah, there's reasons to remove an organ, there's reasons to remove your appendix, there's reasons to do a hysterectomy.
And you got to, you know, weigh out the positives of the negatives, how it's going to help the persons overall help help.
If you're already in a situation where you're not going to necessarily quote, quote, quote, use that organ for reproductive purposes, then, you know, you can, it's an easier decision, but you want to weigh everything out.
Next question, my, a doctor recently shared a successful story whereby a seizure patient who was experiencing 30 seizures per day took folinic acid according to instructions in the bottle and two weeks later was not having seizures at all.
It isn't best to start small if possible in case there's a reaction with seizure medication, how will we know if it's working after two weeks that what tests when we need to check if the possibility of seizures activity.
Now, this is a question that I wish I could just answer. I don't, I am, it's totally case dependent. Are you asking, should you try folinic acid with somebody who was currently having seizures? What are they epileptic seizures? Are they having seizures because of post-concussive issues? Are they having seizures?
Because of Lyme disease are you having seizure, grandma seizures? Are you having seizures? Are you having absent seizures? There's just a plethora of questions that I have with a question like this that make it impossible to answer.
Things like this really need, you need to do a case review with me and we can discuss that if you really want my help with something like this. If you're interested in getting a case review, just go to cuttersclinic.com, you can search, you can go to the tab that says schedule now, you can schedule your own case review complete the whole intake for when we can discuss the full case.
I apologize, but this is just not a question that's not really answerable. And if the person is having seizures, like anything else you want to get to the reason why that you're having seizures and try to deal with that first.
I had patients that had Lyme disease that was causing inflammation in the brain and were having multiple, I had one young gal who was having over 50 absent seizures a day.
As we started working, dealing with the cause of the Lyme disease and inflammation in the brain, she was down to one a day quite quickly and it was just dealing with that cause.
So you're always looking for cause without knowing that there's not like, okay, because this person did this supplement and got this result can't I take that supplement to get the same result if I had similar symptoms.
Well, you can have similar symptoms that are caused from completely different causes. So you want to dig to find out what that cause is.
Back to the chat, what are the negatives to a hysterectomy? Well, again, it depends case by case. So if you're going to do a complete hysterectomy and have your ovaries removed too, then if your postmenopausal already one would argue you're not really using your ovaries, they're not really producing much estrogen and progesterone at that time.
Well, that is partially true. Your ovaries still will produce some estrogen and progesterone.
But if you're just recently metapausal or if you're not metapausal yet, then you will basically put yourself into a metapaus by having your ovaries removed.
The negatives to removing the uterus are less, there's less negatives as far as, you know, they're obviously there's eye negatives, like I mentioned, you could have issues with tipped
and then pooled of urine into bladder and recurrent bladder infections, that's something that can be helped out not completely corrected by doing some different manipulation to the pelvis and manipulation to the bladder.
If you find, you know, a good practitioner, other than that, there's not, you know, horrible growth negatives to getting your uterus removed.
So, you know, we've had clients that have had uterine cancer that was contained in the uterus, but they did not want to have their uterus removed for whatever reasons they were afraid of surgery and such.
And, you know, every case is different, many times we had to kind of talk people into getting over that fear because many times if you can debug what cancer, you can insert in cancers, it can be, it can help tremendously.
So, there's not these, there's not huge negatives, some people would argue the same thing with I'm seeing posts up there about appendix, the ways you can heal appendicitis naturally.
I think it's just, there's, it's kind of foolish, you know, you deal with possible infection that could spread and kill a person.
I just don't think we need to be so afraid of the medical care, even though there's lots of negatives to tenders of care these days, we don't want to just clump everything into that negative bucket even though many things deserve to be clumped into that bucket.
But you have to use wisdom, that's what we're called to use and if the circumstances in the case prevail to push us through all the wisdom that we can, that that would be the best mode of action than we should take the best mode of action.
And I think through prayer and through asking questions, so ask questions of people like me and other people that have had patients that have done hysterectomase, really we haven't seen issues with it.
If you're actually doing a complete hysterectory, removing the organs and you're not in menopause, you're going to put yourself in menopause.
If that's the case, then you really want to support your adredals because your adredals do make progesterone and adjust in estrogen to a lesser extent.
And people that go through menopause, you know, sail through menopause without too many menopausal symptoms are people that have really healthy adredal glands.
But already have fatigue of their adredal glands, they're the ones that go through menopause and have tons of hot flashes and tons of symptoms because of that drop in and rebound of estrogen and progesterone that's sudden when the ovary starts to shut down.
People with really healthy adredal glands don't really notice that because their adredals are making up for it.
So, yeah, there's positive negatives to any surgery too, so I don't want to make it sound like it's easy.
But if you've discussed it with multiple different surgeons, you've discussed it with other doctors and you're doing some study, looking at positives and negatives on the internet, don't be scared of it.
And then you're taking it to prayer and you're deciding what's the best course of action for my case.
Next question, can you help with osteoarthritis pain in hands and back?
So osteoarthritis, there's two different types of arthritis.
There's degenerative arthritis and there's inflammatory arthritis.
Not to say that degenerative arthritis can't be inflammatory, but it is to say that those two classifications of arthritis exist.
And typically the inflammatory arthritis tend to be autoimmune like rheumatoid, psoriatic arthritis, and gaudy arthritis are fall into the inflammatory arthritis category.
Degenerative arthritis or osteoarthritis or degenerative joint disease or degenerative disdisease all are in the degenerative arthritis category.
So, degenerative arthritis is an osteoarthritis, all those are all the same known clature.
So, degenerative arthritis has to do with like wear and tear of a joint.
Degenerative arthritis would be common in, I hurt my knee when I played football in high school.
Now, at 40 years old, my knee has been acting up and it gets swollen at different times if I aggravate it.
You know, I hurt my hands, you know, doing physical work, my whole life and whatever job I did.
And now I get inflammation in my fingers and joints.
And the way the difference in diagnosis has to do with looking at whether you have antibodies of person has rheumatoid antibodies, they would fall into the inflammatory arthritis category and you treat that very different than you would a degenerative arthritis or osteoarthritis.
So, if it's osteoarthritis, you'll see an x-ray, it will look differently too, you'll have, it will just look different on a playing field x-ray, it'll look different on a CT scan and MRI as well.
So, what do you do with degenerative joint disease, degenerative arthritis that's causing pain?
Well, it still is inflammatory in the sense that every time you aggravate it, you have inflammation there and that's really what's causing the pain.
So, you could use anti-inflammatories like flavonoids, so like curcumin as well, stinging nettle, resveratrol, green T-extract, those kinds of things would be good for the inflammation.
The other thing that's good, if it's a degenerative joint disease or osteoarthritis, is cendroitin and glucosamine.
So, especially if it's a larger joint like your knee, even your fingers help with that and certainly shoulders for your hip joint.
Because your joints are tolds that come to their, that they're for my joint castle and in that joint capsule is a fluid and that joint fluid is produced by the joint capsule cells and glucosamine and cendroitin helps stimulate production of that joint fluid.
So, the more fluid you have in there, the more cushion you have of the joint and the less irritation it's going to be.
So, glucosamine and cendroitin typically their sulfite can be beneficial taken for those and using topical anti-inflammatories can be helpful.
Using ornica can be helpful, using CBD products can be helpful, so all those things can be helpful.
If it is osteoarthritis being careful of function, how you're using it, maybe you're walking incorrectly, if it's a knee problem, getting some support, some orthotic support for your feet can be helpful.
Going to a car partner can be helpful, getting physical therapy can be helpful, all those things can be helpful for osteoarthritis.
If it is an inflammatory arthritis and if it is an autoimmune condition connected to it, now that's a whole different ball of wax that we're talking about, still you can be helped with the flavonoids and the anti-inflammatory things, but you need to dig in to find out what the triggers are.
If it's rheumatoid arthritis typically foods that are considered in the category of lectins, that is like potatoes and peppers and tomatoes in that category tend to in general cause more inflammation with rheumatoid arthritis patients, but there can be other food issues that can cause inflammation.
So you have to really, if you think there's an autoimmune connection you got to dig into the triggers for that, like I talked about in that other question.
Going and joining our autoimmune course would be highly recommended, it's super cheap right now, so go to cuttersclinic.com and you can click on the courses, the autoimmune chronic disease and autoimmune course, if you have any suspicion that it is like a rheumatoid or something like that.
Okay, hi, Dr. Cutters, my husband has had two stints put in his heart three months ago.
He's still experiencing some issues when physically exerting himself such as walking uphill or running with, he's had burping, starting, chest pain, left arm hurting.
His cardio doctor doesn't feel it's heart related, as he also does have digestive disorders, but my husband is still concerned mainly, mainly feeling that it could be the heart and he thoughts.
Well, of course, it could be the heart, so what do you do to find out if it's a heart? Well, getting some standard blood testing would be helpful.
And getting a good cardio lipid panel would be helpful.
Certainly, so understand that the same nerves that go to the heart that could give you these symptoms, your doctor is correct, that digestive issues, especially stomach related digestive issues, the upper GI issues, because they follow the same neurological pathway could give you the exact same symptoms.
As a matter of fact, people with indigestion, people with height or hernia issues can get what's called what has been termed as pseudo coronaries, because they can actually feel like an elephant standing in their chest, they feel like they're having a heart attack.
They go in, they run an LDHS negative, they run some other blood panels that show possibility of acute myocardial infarction, they're all negative, they do an EKG and it's all normal.
And then they, you know, everything has passed and they, you know, they call it a pseudo-corporate and they suggest you go to a GI doctor, which typically does you very little good, because they'll put you on something even more horrific, more horrific called prylosec, which is a PBI that blocks all your stomach acid.
The problem really is a deficiency in stomach acid, so highly suggest you go to our website, cuttersclinic.com, in search of the blog.
So we have well over a thousand blog posts, many of them tied to different videos explaining the condition in, you know, and nausea.
And I think one thing that would help you is to go to our blog and search hypochloridria hypochloridria, if you just type that, it will probably come up.
I have a real nice search bar on our website.
Hypochloridria means decrease in stomach acid. Chloridria stands for chloride, its HCl is the stomach acid that these little cells in your stomach call prinal cells make.
And when we eat, you know, emptims, colorings, flavorings, glyphosate, you know, chemicals, we damage those cells and they don't produce enough HCl.
And when we don't produce enough HCl, we don't get proper digestion of food, food goes into the small intestine as a bolus that's only partially digested, it puts a whole lot of stress on our pancreas, it increases the risk of pancreatic inflammation in or pancreatic cancers.
It puts a lot of stress on our liver and our bile duct, our bile system, which secretes digestive enzymes for lipids.
And it really stems from a decreased stomach acid.
So hypochloridria will cause the food to sit in your stomach longer than it should because it's not being digested in the little stomach acids you have can purgitate up into your esophagus.
You can burp it up when you have acid and then you think, oh, I have too much stomach acid, you go on a PPI or go take tons or role aids or something like that, you're actually causing worse problems.
You would agree with the doctor that you should investigate that first.
I mean, you could know fairly quickly if you start taking HCl, if you go to that blog post and I have a blog post on helicobacter pylori because having chronic HCl deficiency is going to set a person up for Hpylori infections.
And so I have a blog post on that as well that you should probably read too.
So it's kind of a simple fix in the sense of what you need to do is start taking HCl and digestive enzymes with your meals.
However, if you already have it also because of a decrease stomach acid, yes, you get it also because of a decrease stomach acid because a decrease stomach acid allows the continued growth of the opportunistic organism that's called helicobacter pylori and that's what causes a stomach ulcer.
So that stomach ulcer will then be irritated by the HCl.
So if you take HCl and it's like, oh, my gosh, I really hurt my stomach.
You need to back off and try to heal the stomach with a decrease or a decrease or some other things to help heal your stomach lighting.
And then in a couple of weeks go back on the HCl or just try apple cider vinegar for a while, which is a little bit milder acid.
And then get on the HCl. So there's a process so I lay it out in that blog post so I lay out the whole way to start that process and to take care of that problem in that blog post and to deal with Hpylori as well.
So yeah, you do want to get your heart checked? Yes, absolutely. We do want to get your digestive system corrected because you talk about coronary issues in Hpylori.
Hpylori is one of the top four causes of coronary, heartary disease.
So yes, Hpylori goes beyond the stomach, goes the stomach and causes inflammation and damage to the endothelial cells.
Those are the cells that line the arteries and it can get underneath the endothelial lining in the heart and damage the smooth muscle cells damage the receptor sites, the ACE receptors and other receptors cause blood pressure issues.
Cause inflammation in the endothelial lining and cause heart disease.
So dealing with so many things stem from this from digestion stem from the stomach.
So that's really where you need to start.
So, you know, if you have, oh, I have a serious disease, I have cancer when you should still start healing the gut. I have serious disease, I have heart disease.
Well, you still should start dealing, you know, heal the gut not that you don't deal with those other things, but you got to heal the gut as well.
Okay, so again, go to cuttersclinic.com, search hypochloridria, search helicobacter pylori or Hpylori.
And you'll find that those blog posts that go into that what I'm just saying in detail and I know they have some videos on them too.
Okay, next question. What are your thoughts on very low dose, three milligrams of Naltrexel before line patients.
So, low dose Naltrexel or LDN is its even term now is an off label use of a drug that was approved years ago to help get people off addictions.
It's a drug called Naltrexel. It was typically approved on I think 50 milligrams to get people off of addictive substances.
But they found that low doses of Naltrexel act as an immune regulator.
So, it up regulates T-reg cells. So, understand your immune cells in your body, you have TH1, migory, and T, there's a couple of different ways to classify an immune response.
What is a TH1 versus a TH2 response?
TH1 is an immediate immune response. It's an inflammatory response. It's how you kill pathogens. A TH2 response is a secondary response. It's a cell mediated response.
It's a B cell response. It's how you make antibodies to take pathogens so that the TH1 response can fire again and kill those pathogens.
The problem is that with autoimmune diseases, we can have this constant up regulation of a TH1 response and you guys damage to cell membranes, damage to cells that you have antibodies.
So, remember any time you have antibodies to yourself, let's say you have antibodies to a thyroid gland.
So, any time you stimulate an immune response, any time you have an optic of that TH1 response, and if you have a chronic optic of that TH1 response, usually because you're not dealing with a trigger, then you're going to be constantly killing your thyroid gland.
You're going to be constantly destroying that which you have antibodies against.
Any time you have an up regulation of your immune system, whether you do it artificially because you are inadvertently and ignorantly taking immune stimulants.
They have an autoimmune disease that I keep taking vitamin C and garlic because my doctor told me to take it because I have chronic Lyme.
So, why should we take cats, claws, garlic and vitamin C? Well, what if you already have antibodies to self-tissue?
Every time you're taking that substance, you're stimulating immune response, and every time you stimulate immune response, you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against.
And if you have antibodies against your own body, you have antibodies against self-tissue, aka you have an autoimmune disease that has been undiagnosed,
then you are going to cause more inflammation, more damage, more symptoms.
And a lot of those people go, oh my gosh, I have a Lyme player. You don't really have a Lyme player.
You are causing damage to your own cells, so stop taking those immune stimulants.
Okay, maybe you're beyond that point and you've educated yourself and now you're knowledgeable of that.
Boy, I haven't taken immune stimulants for a whole long time, but I keep getting these flares, my Lyme keeps flaring up.
Well, you got to look for other triggers, like we talked about with other questions, you got to dig in to find, are there any foods that are triggers?
Well, I'm already dairy free and gluten free, so what else could it be? Could be a ton of other things.
Could be anything else, you need to test for that.
There's other triggers too, maybe it's the smell of gasoline, maybe it's the smell of mold, maybe it's the smell of perfume, maybe it's things that there's just a zillion things that could be triggers.
You're going to put on your Sherlock Holmes hat and figure this out, because nobody can completely, you can't test for all these things.
You've got to try to figure out what are your triggers.
Now, there are some things that are what aren't called T-reg stimulators.
So, whenever I say there's a TH1 response and a TH2 response and people that have constant autoimmune flares are stuck in a TH1 dominant situation, maybe by their own making, like I said.
But there are some nutritional things and some off label medication that can stimulate T-reg cells.
T-reg cells can help calm down a TH1 response and calm down a TH2 response. They help balance that.
So, T-reg stimulators can be good to take. Vitamin D is actually a T-reg stimulator. It's not an immune stimulator.
And what this person asked, LDL low dose nail track, so it's been found to be a T-reg stimulator.
So, that's why it's been found to be helpful for autoimmune conditions, because it helps calm down that TH1 response.
So, yes, so it could be helpful. Typically, people start by taking 1.5 milligrams, go up to 3 milligrams, and go up to 4.5 milligrams.
And that's considered, as in the person's weight too, but that's considered low dose nail track cell and it could be very beneficial for autoimmune patients.
Next question, what is the best natural treatment for multiple sclerosis? Well, understand, multiple sclerosis is kind of multiple causes.
So, multiple sclerosis is a demilinated disease. We need that. Something is destroyed the myelin sheath.
So, the myelin sheath is the sheath that end your neurons in your brain. So, you have neurons in your brain that are covered in myelin and it causes the connection, the communication along that neuron to be sped up tremendously.
So, when we have a disorder that breaks down that myelin, then we could have issues with that nerve communication.
It's not going to function as well, and then you end up with issues. So, if you have a demilinated disease that's demilinated motor neurons that are going to your arm, you could have issues with arm function, you could have all sorts of problems.
So, depending on where that demilination is, is where you're going to have problems.
Multiple sclerosis is plackied of the myelin sheath and break down of that myelin sheath. So, what you'll see with multiple sclerosis, if you did an antibody neural antibody test, you'll typically have antibodies against myelin sheath cells.
So, you'll have antibodies against myelin. So, you'll have a destruction of myelin. So, it's an autoimmune disorder.
Now, again, what was the cause of that? It could be a myriad of different causes.
First, we can end up with myelin sheath and myelin antibodies post concussion. They had a concussion 10 years ago playing hockey ski accident car accident 15 years ago.
And now they're having upper motor neuron symptoms, meaning they're having issues with with motion. They're having a function of muscles motor neurons. They're having issues with with sensory issues.
And then you do an MRI and all your plackied of your myelin sheath cells, you have demilination going on, and you have multiple sclerosis.
Okay, well, again, that doesn't help at all. And all they do is give you a drug that is mildly beneficial for some people.
You have to dig into cause, you have to dig into everything that you would dig into with an autoimmune disease.
So, you test for neuronal antibodies, you'll definitely see if you have plackied of the myelin in multiple sclerosis, you're going to definitely see myelin antibodies possibly other antibodies.
You look at the cross reactants to those cross reactions to myelin is gluten. So, you're going to go off of some things immediately go on a gluten free diet.
Also, want to test for other triggers. You want to do a Syrex array 10, at least, where you're looking for other food triggers, and you're trying to calm down the immune system.
So, definitely go off of any immune stimulant supplements that you're taking, anything else you're doing to stimulate the immune system.
Because again, every time you stimulate the immune system, when you have self antibodies, you're going to create further destruction.
So, why do some people have multiple sclerosis that can manage it quite well, and they don't seem to have a lot of progression because they're doing these things.
Other people, they're multiple sclerosis progresses quite quickly, because they're not doing these things.
With any autoimmune disease, you can't necessarily cure it, but you can manage it if you find your triggers, and it takes time.
So, don't beat yourself up, but you find your triggers, and you remove those triggers and you calm down the whole response.
Definitely, with any neuronal antibodies, and that's with multiple sclerosis, with myelin antibodies, we follow that, has to be no alcohol as well.
They found, with studies that alcohol increases the inflammation, the brain is going to increase the damage and destruction of the myelin she sells.
So, natural treatment for multiple sclerosis is to, it's really an autoimmune disorder, so you're going down that whole autoimmune pathway, looking for triggers, looking for things that stimulate the immune system, and you're going to calm those down, you're going to change your diet, change your nutritional protocol, make sure you're not taking any immune stimulants, and you go down that pathway to discover any new triggers that you have.
And once you call that down, you can decrease progression.
And really, that's really the treatment. I don't want to simplify because it isn't simple because you're digging and you have to run some tests to find out what these are, and you have to, you know, be diligent about, about looking for triggers and trying to remove those from your diet.
So, it's not easy, I'm not saying it's easy, but this is how you're going to save your life.
So, it's not something you should take lightly, because, you know, an autoimmune disease has multiple different phases, the more destruction you have, you have destruction of myelin she sells.
I mean, they're gone. So, it's not good when that happens, so, the oligodendercytes are not going to grow back.
So, you, you have to stop that progression in its tracks as fast as possible.
Okay, next question, is the beamer a good PEMF unit?
So, the beamer is a low Gauss PEMF. So, PEMF units are measured in the Gauss output of electricity.
The low Gauss output PEMFs on the market to that are popular is the IMRS and the beamer brands.
Are they good units?
You know, if you have them, use them.
Unfortunately, you know, all the research on PEMF, there's a plethora of research for PEMF on how PEMF, which is pulse electromagnetic field therapy, it's electrical pulse.
PEMF therapy can be extremely beneficial to improve cell membrane potential, increase the cell charge, increase person's health in so many ways, it can be very beneficial.
It can decrease inflammation to talk about, you know, things that will help osteoarthritis or degenerative arthritis or even inflammatory arthritis, PEMF is great for that.
However, all the research on PEMF was done with high Gauss PEMF units. Are you giving an example? So, the beamer and the IMRS function under a thousand Gauss, I think they're like 700 Gauss.
Professional PEMF is between 25 and 30,000 Gauss. That's a big difference. 25,000 Gauss versus 700 Gauss. That's a big difference.
So, you can't really, I know those companies steal that data in a sense and say, see, we're a PEMF machine and look at all this wonderful data, how it does all this wonderful stuff.
Well, it's not really a real fair comparison because that was tested with 25 to 30,000 Gauss machine, all those studies, that on a machine that puts out 700 Gauss.
Now, I'm not saying that these low Gauss PEMFs don't have benefit. I think they all have benefit. I just don't know that they have the same benefit as a good quality PEMF.
The problem is that their good quality PEMF machine is super expensive. Like, you know, we have a PEMF in our office, it's 30,000 Gauss PEMF, but they're also 38,000 dollars.
Well, who's going to buy that for their house? Nobody. But you can buy a good, you know, or a BEMF might cost you $7,000, $9,000, you can buy a 7,000 Gauss PEMF, which a lot of clinics have.
You might go to a car project or a physical therapist that uses a PEMF, but it's a 7,000 Gauss PEMF. It's much better quality PEMF than a 700 Gauss PEMF.
So, is it a good PEMF unit? Yeah, if you haven't used it, it's better than nothing. Would I spend $7,000, $5,000, $3,000 on one of those? No, no, I wouldn't. If I was going to spend, you know, if I had a limited budget, if I could afford a $9,000, $7,000 Gauss PEMF, I would choose that.
Or I'd save up to get that, honestly. So, yeah, I don't want to knock a company. I just think they oversell, and they're not really using correct data.
I don't like that when companies, it's not incorrect, but it's not really data that's based upon the Gauss output of your machine.
So, it's like a laser company, there's different levels of laser, class 1, 2, 3, 4 of laser. Well, all the research on lasers done with a class 4 laser, then a company that's selling a class 2 laser is pilfery that data and say, look at what laser does.
Well, yeah, you're still a laser company, you still sell a laser, but it's not going to do the exact same thing as a class 4 laser. It's just not really fair, but still a class 2 laser is better than no laser, I guess.
Okay, we have time for one more question. Is it possible for a person to take too many supplements? Is it possible for a person to take too many supplements? Yes, it is.
So, for sure, it's even more probable than a person's taking incorrect supplements.
So, I think I have a blog post, I think I have a blog post on minerals, I did it a number of years ago, it's worth looking at it. That's what we see a lot. I think it's good to evaluate your supplements.
People will be taking like a multiple, a multiple mineral or a multiple vitamin, and it's got things in it that nobody should be consuming. Here's an example, I just said a chat with somebody this morning that was put on folic acid.
Well, folic acid as folic acid, folic acid is synthetic folate, understand. So, it was named folic acid when they synthesized it back in the 1950s when they discovered folate.
Remember folate is the B vitamin that's found in foliage hence the name. So, in green leafy vegetables folate is found.
So, they found that folate deficiencies caused neural tube defects with women were pregnant with babies and they had folate deficiency. So, they synthesized folate in the laboratory called folic acid.
So, folic acid would you look at a label and says folic acid as folic acid, then it's synthetic folate.
Some companies will still say folic acid as metal tetrahedral folate, then it's the right form of folate or folic acid as folic acid and folidate, then it's the right folic acid.
However, there's still a lot of companies out there that really don't care about what they put in their supplements, they only care about celly supplements.
Yeah, so more than taking too many supplements, which that could be a problem, I see people taking incorrect things or poor quality supplements, poor quality minerals, elemental minerals, oh boy, that's like just poison for your body.
I have blog posts on that as well, so look that up, correct type of minerals, how it should be taken way you'd eat it in nature, double bonded to it, amino acid, how you'd eat it in a vegetable or in a good quality grass fed beef, how you'd get it in that, not how you'd it from the ground, we don't eat dirt to get our minerals.
And then taking taking supplements, you talk about too many supplements, taking supplements incorrectly based upon your condition, you see cancer patients taking copper.
No, no, cancer patients not take copper, copper is in a is a growth support, it will stimulate growth cell growth cell replication.
Cancer patients should not take a lot of methyl groups for reasons that methyl groups can silence tuber suppressor genes, if you need healthy function of your tuber suppressor genes, if you're going to stimulate intrinsic apoptosis of cancer cells.
Cancer patients should be taking antioxidants, if you're trying to kill cancer, if you already know you have cancer, you should change your, there's things that you should do.
If you don't have cancer, there's totally different things you should do, if you were diagnosed with cancer.
There's things that you do, if you have a heart disease, and totally different things that you should do, if you have cancer.
Cancer should not be taking nitric oxide, if you have heart disease, but not cancer, nitric oxide can be extremely beneficial.
If you're trying to prevent cancer, antioxidants are a very wise thing to be taking, but if you already have cancer, you shouldn't be taking antioxidants because you want to create a pro oxidative stress to a cancer cell in order to kill it.
So, there's, it really depends on your condition, you should conduct, you should have, you know, communication with the practitioner who knows these things.
And unfortunately, I talked to a lot of people that come from practitioners that have a serious disease, and there are other things that they should not be taking that could actually be promoting their cancer.
And that's not a wise thing, so you've got to talk to somebody who knows what they're doing for that condition, because it is very different. I just wish it was just real simple, but it's not, it's just not that simple.
So, last question came out of the blog, is there harm in long term use of apple cider vinegar?
I add one tablespoonish to my tea, 20 ounces of water.
No, so apple cider vinegar is a sedic acid, so it's a milder acid than HCl.
So, what would it be the purpose of taking apple cider vinegar? The purpose is to help acidify your stomach.
So, can you take it on an empty stomach? Yeah, you can. Would it be, maybe better for you if you take it with your meal or before a meal?
It will help you break down the meal and help you digest your food, so yes, but you can take it on an empty stomach too.
No, it's zero harm and take long term use of taking apple cider vinegar. No, it's good for you and the, and it's, it's just go back to my blog, got it.
Connorsledic.com look at hypochloridria, and you'll find that the number one cause of ill health worldwide is hypochloridria, which leads to all sorts of problems downstream years and years later, even cancer.
Anything you can do to help acidify your stomach better off you could do.
Opposite of that would be just foolish things like I'm taking, you know, high pH water, wrong. That's just the wrong thing.
I'm taking, I'm taking baking soda because I want to kill cancer in my breast, wrong.
That doesn't work that way. All you're doing is, is alkalizing your stomach and causing more cold morbidities.
You're certainly not alkalizing the cancer by taking baking soda in your stomach, unless you actually had stomach cancer.
So, and stomach cancer is most commonly caused from H. Pylori, which is caused from hypochloridria.
Yeah, so we can make mistakes. There's a lot of ill information, just completely wrong information out there and even practitioners that don't understand all conditions and, you know, want to sell you stuff and supplements.
So yeah, you can take too many things. I've had people come to me and they're taking a hundred different supplements. It's like, gosh.
So, yeah, yes, you could take too many supplements. Yes, you can be taking the wrong thing.
And that can be too much of a good thing, can be a bad thing. It's my saying.
So, hopefully it helps.
If you want to go to holistic health hour, if you want to submit questions beforehand, so you can get them on, you can also see all our past holistic health hours really nicely indexed by topic as well.
And go to caudersclinic.com if you want to make an appointment with me, you can through self schedule right there.
If you want to just talk to us, you can call us too, but certainly look at our blogs, look at our courses, they're pretty darn cheap.
And our blogs are pretty darn cheap too, because they're free.
So, go to our blogs, we have a nice index and search on our site as well.
All right. God bless. Thanks for being with us. And we will not see you next week. We'll not have a holistic health hour next week. I'll be gone with the week after. Bye bye.